passer à la catégorie meilleur rating de
l'année regardez avait du coup 1
pour le trophée du happening de l'année
[Musique]
matthieu delormeau
attention ce que vous êtes prêts les
gars
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
[Musique]
gore
[Rires]
isabelle morini bosc
à l'étroit d'oeil à ces partis
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça
ils n'arrivent pas par ailleurs mr aussi
rapidement
et gilles verdez
aussi c'est pas 5 m en fait c'est ses 60
ne dit pas s'il ya un truc ne pique pas
syrie n'ont quoi bon car tu donnes le
top
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est à voir
et deschamps démarre
gd santé pour un bordel
[Musique]
alors pour vous quel est le meilleur à
filgoal à dix jours afin que les fautes
directes si vous nous rejoignez si
j'avais naguère isabelle t-il
jjg fait on a peur pour lui à gilles
j'avoue t.gil si vous me l'aviez fait sa
job et bien on va voir qui a été choisi
et vous avez compris puisqu'elle n'est
pas la ville gagnant isabelle morini
bosc
[Applaudissements]